اوقاتكم اهلا بكم هذه التغطيه مستمره ما
زلنا نبحث عن الامل بين
مئات المباني التي تحتضن وتخفي تحتها
اصوات بعضها خفت وبعضها يصارع الموت املا
في انقاذه
مشاهدينا تطورات فاجعه لهذا الزلزال
المدمر الذي ضرب سوريا وتركيا عمليات
الانقاذ متواصله وسط تحديات صعوبات تواجه
فرق الانقاذ ابرزها الظروف الجويه السيئه
مستمرون معكم لتغطيه العربيه لحظه بلحظه
لاخر تطورات الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب
سوريا وتركيا حيث تستمر هذه العمليات
واسطه ظروف جويه سيئه ووسط انتظار لمزيد
من المعونات لمزيد من فرق الانقاذ التي
تنبش ما بين الركام لتخرج احياء ولربما
تخرج جثه لتزيد عدد القتلى هناك نتابع
قفز عدد قتل الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب جنوب
تركيا وسوريا الى اكثر من ثمانيه الاف
واربع مئه شخص في البلدين فيما لا يزال
رجال الانقاذ يسابقون الزمن في ظروف
الشتاء القاسيه لانتشال الناجين من تحت
انقاذ المباني المنهاره ففي تركيا اعلنتها
السلطات مقتله
5894 شخصا واصابه اكثر من 34 الف اخرين
فيما دخل قرروا اعلان حاله طوارئ حيز
التنفيذ في الولايات المتضرره من الزلزال
في سوريا بلغ عدد القتلى
2500 شخص على الاقل وفقا للمرصد السوري
لحقوق الانسان هذا وواصل عماله الانقاذ
العمل خلال الليل وحتى الصباح بحثا عن
ناجين فيما انتظر الناس بجوار اكوام
الانقاض على امل العثور على اصدقائهم او
اقاربهم احياء
حصيله ضحايا الزلزال سجلت مقتله 5000
وثمانمائه واربعه وتسعين شخصا واصابه
اربعه وثلاثين الفمائه وعشره اخرين كما
دمرت
5775 بنايه فرقنا تواصل العمل لانقاذ من
لا يزال على قيد الحياه ونجحت في اغاثه ما
يقارب من ثمانيه الاف شخص كانوا تحت
الانقاض
اظهرت مقاطع فيديو لحظه تعرض منطقه كهرمان
مرعش في تركيا الى زلزال جديد اسفر عن
انهيار احد المباني السكنيه مخلفا حاله من
الفزع بين السكان
[موسيقى]
من القامشلي عبر سكايب مراسل العربيه جمعه
عكاش جمعه ما الذي خلفك وضعني في تفاصيل
الصوره لديك اذا تكرمت
صباح الخير
من الاخبار الجيده اليوم بان الامطار
والثلوج توقفت عن كامل سوريا وبدات الشمس
تشرق عسى تمسح بعضا من البرد الذي معناها
السوريين خلال هذه
الكارثه اي ان يعني الظروف الجويه اصبحت
مؤاتيه اكثر امام فرق الانقاذ لاكمال يعني
مسيرتها في الناجين حتى جلست من تحت هذه
الانقاض المتراكمه في عدد كبير من المدن
السوريه اما عادل عن ما هو خلفيه الان هي
مجموعه من القيم تم وضعها في ملعب انتفاضه
12 اذار في مدينه القامشلي تحسبا لحدوث اي
هزات ارتداديه لزلزالي تركيا قد تجبر
الاهالي الخروج من المنازل
يعني اللجوء الى هذه القيم طبعا هناك حركه
مقبوله على هذه الخيام خاصه ليله امس بعض
الناس حتى الان يعني تخشى البقاء في
المنازل وتفضل اللجوء الى هذه القيم
المؤقته او مراكز لواء المواقته وايضا
تفضل الذهاب باتجاه الارياف للسكن مع
الاقارب او الاهل خاصه اولئك الذين يسكنون
في المباني العموديه متعدده التوابق جمعه
اعلم الظروف صعبه ولكن هل تمت ارقام
احصائيات عدد الناجين عدد القتلى الجرحى
المباني المهدمه كل ذلك ربما نحن بانتظار
سماع ارقام ومعرفه الصوره اكثر
يعني بعد مرور يومين على هذا الزلزال
اصبحت الصوره واضحه بشكل جيد بالنسبه
للارقام يعني حصيله اعداد الذين فقدوا
حياتهم في هذا الزلزال يقترب من 2500 في
عموم المناطق السوريه المتضرره وتحديدا في
المدن الاربعه الاكثر تضررا
حمى ادلب حلب اللاذقيه وبشكل متفاوت طرطوس
وجبله اما اعداد الجرعه هناك 3500 جريحه
او لا تم قيدهم في السجلات المشافي
والنقاط الطبيه والعيادات المتنقله لكن
عدد الجرحى يكون اكبر من ذلك لان المشافي
لم تستطع استقبال المزيد منه وبالتالي لم
يتم تسجيلهم اضافه الى عدد كبير من
المصابين والجرحى قاموا بمداواه انفسكم
ذاتيا خارج المشافي والنقاط الطبيه
المتخصصه من الاخبار الجيده ايضا بان
الناجين اعداد الذين تم انتشالهم من تحت
الالقاب على كامل الجغرافيا السوريه بلغ
حوالي 520 حتى الان بجمع احصائيتي النظام
ومناطق المعارضه وهو عدد ارتفع بحوالي 100
وثلاثه اشخاص عما كان عليه يوم امس بما
يعني ان جهود يعني ازاله الارقام واخراج
الاحياء من تحت هذه الالقاب تكللت بنجاح
مقبول ان نتحدث عن اضافه نيو ثلاثه اشخاص
خلال يعني بضع ساعات رغم انه يعني
العمليات كانت تتم في الليل وكان هناك
صعوبه في الوصول الى هؤلاء الاسماء في ظل
يعني ضعف الامكانيات ضعف المعدات وايضا
ضعف الخبره في الوصول اليهم المباني
المنهاره حتى الان عادل يعني عددها وصل
الى حوالي 300 مبنى منهار بالكامل
يتقاسم مناطق النظام والمعارضه العدد 150
لكن هناك الالاف من المباني المتضرره التي
تشهد شقوق وتصدعات والتي يطلب منها
الاهالي من قبل الجهات المتخصصه بعدم
العوده اليها خوفا من حدوث ايه هزات
ارتداديه لربما تؤدي الى سقوط هذه المنازل
فوق السكان في حاله وعادوا الى هذه
المنازل وهذا يفسر عدد الكبير من الناس
الذين بقوا حتى الخارج هذه المدن الاربعه
الرئيسيه شمال غرب سوريا وايضا مناطق
الساحل والداخل السوريين اين ذهب هؤلاء
الناس الذين تركوا بيوتهم يعني البعض
يتحدث عن انهم قد باتوا ليلتهم ايضا في
العراق
عادل الناس تضررت بشكل بعض الناس تضررت
بشكل مباح
قشره اولئك الذين خسروا او حدثت فيها
تشققات والتصدعات وهناك من تضرر بشكل غير
مباشر الذين يخافون البقاء في المنازل
وخرجوا الجميع اما ذهبوا باتجاه مراكز
الايواء المؤقته سواء في الملاعب المغلقه
او صلاه الافراح وبعضهم في المساجد خاصه
في اللاذقيه وبعضهم في الكنائس والبعض
الاخر ذهبوا باتجاه الارياف
وما لدي مثلا بيوت مع الاصدقاء او الاقارب
او حتى مع الناس الغرباء البيوت العربيه
المؤلفه مطابق واحد ذهب ونجاوا اليها
بينما هناك الالاف في الحدائق العامه
خلال الليلتين الماضيتين جمعه ارجو ان
تبقى معي ساعود اليك لكن اذهب الى اضنه
ومن هناك معي زيدان زنكلو مراسل العربيه
زيدان اهلا بك ما هو الوضع لديك الى اين
وصلت جهود الانقاذ
نعم جهود الانقاذ مستمره بعد اكثر من 48
ساعه على حدوث الزلزال يعني ما تزال
جهودها لانقاذ مستمره هنا في اضنه كما في
سائر الولايات العشر المنكوبه في هذا
الموقع الذي نتواجد فيه منذ يوم امس عدنا
اليك قبل قليل نشاهد جهود الانقاذ مستمره
يعني يعني مع الاسف تم اخراج
عدد من الضحايا من تحت الانقاض يعني هذا
يعني ارتفاع اكثر في عدد الضحايا الان
هناك يحاولون ايضا انتشال على ما يبدو
ايضا يخفى اخرى ننتظر الكاميرا نحاول
زميلها المصور ان يرصد المشهد
من هنا ايضا صباح هذا اليوم وصل فريق
انقاذ من المتطوعين الاجانب لا ندري
بالضبط ما هي جنسيه الفريق الذي وصل
للمشاركه في جهودها لانقاذ الليله الماضيه
كان هناك ام في البحث عن جي يقال انه لا
نعلم حتى الان اين وصلت
لا
الوفد الموجود هنا في الموقع ليس وفدا
صينية
نعم نعم اتحدث عن الموقع الموجود فيه الان
انا هناك عدد من الطرق الطاقم اجنبي
اوروبي حتى الان لم نتاكد من جنسيه الطاقم
لكن بالعموم
كما نتابع معكم على ما يبدو الان تم اخراج
ضحيه او جثه اخرى من تحت الانقاض هذا ما
يبدو الينا ما يبدو لنا الان في هذه
الصوره سنحاول ايضا الحديث عن هذا الموضوع
زيدان اعلم لربما
ولكن ماذا تقول او ماذا يقول عمالنا
لانقاذ خاصه بعد مرور كمان 48 ساعه هل من
الممكن ان تؤدي جهودهم الى انقاذ مزيد من
الارواح او فقط انتشال هذه الجثث
نعم يعني ما تزال هناك يعني جهود على
الانقاذ مستمر الان اخرجوا الجثه سينقلون
الى خارج الموقع طبعا
سياره الاسعاف تحاول او هناك اسعاف قريبه
الان يتم نقل الضحيه كما نشاهدها لا ادري
اذا كانت الكاميرا بتستطيع ان ترصد هذا
المشهد تم فتح تم فتح الثغره في هذا
المكان كان هناك يوم امس عندما كنا في هذا
الموقع كان هناك امل كان هناك ناجون داخل
هذا او تحت هذا الركام استطاعوا الحديث
استطاعت فرق الانقاذ الحديث مع
بعض الناجين ومن ثم حاولوا الوصول لكن على
ما يبدو ان الجهود ما تزال مستمره لا نعلم
حتى الان اذا كان حتى الان في هذا الموقع
هناك احياء جهود الانقاذ ما تزال مستمره
الخبراء هناك خبراء متخصصون بهذا الموضوع
في اداره الكوارث والتعامل
من يقودون هذه العمليه طبعا عشرات
المتطوعين وايضا من فرق الانقاذ المتخصصه
لكن هناك فريق كان فريق تركي يشرف على هذا
الموضوع ووصل صباح هذا اليوم اعيد تاكيدات
المعلومه فريق اجنبي بالعموم اليوم
محاولات ما تزال مستمره نعم يعني الوضع
يعني يبدو صعب بعد مرور اكثر من 48 ساعه
ان كان في اضنه او في بقيه المناطق لكن
هذا اليوم يعني يعد يوم حاسم بالنسبه
للسلطات التركيه كما صرح اكثر من مسؤول
يوم امس لان اعداد
اطقم الانقاذ تقريبا ستتضاعف مع كامل
الاليات التي تصل تباعا الى المناطق
المنكوبه خصوصا الى ولايتي هاتاي وكهرمان
مرعش طبعا هاتان الولاياتان هم هما الاكثر
تضررا نتيجه الزلزال وهناك الاف المباني
المدمره في كلتا
الولايتين وبالتالي الجهود هناك بحاجه او
المطلوب هنا لجهود اكثر وفرق تطوعيه اكثر
وفرق انقاذ متخصصه اكثر مزوده بكل الاليات
والامكانيات المتطوره للكشف والوصول الى
في محاوله الوصول الى الناجين نعم لا شك
نعم يعني زيدان بودي ان يتساءل ما هي
المعوقات التي تقف امامها فرق الانقاذ
وتصعب من مهمتها اليوم
لا شك ان المعوقات يعني اليوم في اليوم
الثالث بدانا في اليوم الثالث من منذ يوم
الكارثه يعني اليوم تقريبا المعوقات التي
كانت موجوده في اليوم الاول او في
ساعه الاولى تقريبا قد ازيل معظمها وهي
اولا المعوقات التي ترتبط بالظروف الجويه
السيئه التي تسود هذه المنطقه بشكل عام
والتي ادت الى تعطل الطرق لكن الم يبدو ان
الامور في تحسن نوعا ما مع زياده عدد
الاليات التي تستطيع فتح الطرق ايضا كانت
بعض الطرق مدمره نتيجه
الانهيارات التي حصلت او تشققات في بعض
الطرق نتيجه الزلزال ايضا تم توفير طرق
بديله لكن هذا الموضوع ادى الى تاخير وصول
بعض خصوصا المعدات الثقيله والاليات
الثقيله اليات الحفر الثقيله هذه التي لا
يمكن جوا وانما يتطلب نقلها حصرا عن طريق
البرد وبالتالي هذا الموضوع اخر بعض الشيء
اصول الاليات والمعدات اللوجستيه اللازمه
لفرق الانقاذ التي كانت تعمل النقطه
الثالثه وهي الاهم طبعا ان حجم الدمار او
ان الاثار السلبيه او الدمار الذي سببه
الزلزال طالع 10 ولايات في وقت واحد وهذا
موضوع يعني جغرافيا كبير جدا هذه المناطق
يقطنها اكثر من ثلاثه عشر مليون شخص
وبمسافه جغرافيه او بمساحه جغرافيه كبيره
جدا هذا يتطلب
امكانيات كبيره جدا وايضا يتطلب مساعدات
ايضا كبيره جدا هذه هي كانت باختصار يعني
العوائق التي اثرت سلبا في وصول فرق
الانقاذ الى كل المناطق المنكوبه
بالوقت المناسب
يعني زيدان ارجو ان تبقى معي وتترك لنا
هذه الصوره المباشره ايضا وساعود اليك بعد
قليل
اذا تكرمت
في سوريا تتواصل عمليات ازاله الانقاض
والبحث عن اناجينا بسبب الزلزال المدمر
العربي حصلت على مقاطع خاصه تظهر جهود
الانقاب
في مرت اخوي توفت
وبنتها طالب الجامعه
ببني ياسر مشفى بانياس
جينا الساعه 8:00 الصبح كانت الاليات
الشغيله والعمال عم تشتغل وتاثير الله
يعطيه العافيه
[موسيقى]
نعود الى القامشلي وتحديدا مع جمعه عكاشه
جمعه كنا نتحدث عن جهود الانقاذ الامدادات
هل تصل الى هذه المناطق الطرقات تسمح بذلك
ام ان هي رغم شح هذه الامدادات الا ان
هناك معوقات لايصالها وهي بعيده عن
المحتاجين لها
عدل يعني يمكن تقسيم المناطق المتضرره الى
منطقتين من حيث استقبال المساعدات
الانسانيه والدوليه مناطق النظام ومناطق
المعارضه يعني
المساعدات بدات يعني تتدفق منذ يوم امس
حتى الان وصلت طائرات من مصر من الجزائر
من ايران من ليبيا ومن الامارات الى مطار
دمشق الدولي ومطار حلب الدولي هذه الدول
الخمس قدمت مساعدات اغاثيه طبيه وخيام
وبطانيات المساعدات تذهب
ويتم استقبالها من قبل الهلال الاحمر
العربي السوري وحتى الان تتجه نحو المدن
الثلاث المنكوبه تحت السيطره النظام نتحدث
عن حماه اللاذقيه
والاجزاء الجنوبيه ومركز مدينه حلب لكن
بخصوص مناطق المعارضه حتى هذه اللحظه
يمكنه ان اؤكد لك بانها لم تتلقى اي نوع
من المساعدات لا من الطرف السوري ولا حتى
من الطرف التركي بسبب وجود عدد من
المعوقات لعل ابرزها غياب اي تفاهم او اي
تنسيق على مستوى المعارضه والنظام لتسهيل
الدخول هذه المساعدات المقدمه من الدول
وايضا من المنظمات الدوليه كالامم المتحده
مدير شؤون اللاجئين خلال الاحمر والصليب
الاحمر الدوليين ايضا من معبر باب الهوى
المعبر الرسمي الوحيد المعترف فيه من قبل
مجلس الامن الدولي والمعتمد ضمن سياق
اليات قال المساعدات العاجله الى سوريا لم
يشهد اي ادخال للمساعدات الامميه رغم انه
عندما تواصلنا مع الامم المتحده قالوا بان
هناك شاحنات لكن وجود يعني مشاكل في
الطريق يعني تكسر الطريق في بعض المناطق
خاصه في ولايه هاتايا القريبه من المعبر
يقول دون وصول هذه المساعدات لذلك عادل
هناك يعني لتجاوز هذه العقبات السياسيه
بين نظام والمعارضه وجود عقبات على الارض
من من تركيا لابد من ايجاد الجسر جوي بين
الدول الداعمه او الراغبه في مساعده هذا
الجزء المتضرر شمال غرب البلاد ايجاد جسر
جوي لنقل
المساعدات دون ذلك سيكون الوضع كارثي
وماساوي عادل نحن لا نتحدث فقط عن مئات
الاشخاص على قيم تحت الانقاذ نحن نتحدث عن
حوالي 7 مليون انسان متضرر بشكل مباشر
وغير مباشر عن هذا الزلزال الجرحى يحتاجون
الى ادويه المشاردون يحتاجون الى ماوى
وغذاء وصحه
كل هؤلاء متضررين وبالتالي لابد من
مساعدات انسانيه عاجله الى هذا الجزء
المنكوب من سوريا المنظمات الدوليه
العامله قبل هذا الزلزال في سوريا هل
بالفعل حولت كل المساعدات الى
المحتاجين لها ما بعد الزلزال او ضحايا
هذا الزلزال هل تساهم هل تشاهدون ذلك هل
هو ملموس على الارض هل يتم الحديث من قبل
اي الجهات الرسميه سواء لدى المعارضه او
حتى النظام
بخصوص يعني المنظمه الافضل التي تعمل في
عموم سوريا يعني خلال السنوات الماضيه هي
مفوضيه شؤون اللاجئين يوم امس كان لديهم
تصريح كانوا قاموا بتوزيع سلاب غذائيه في
المناطق التي يسيطر عليها النظام خاصه في
اللاذقيه من حلب
وحماه بينما في مناطق المعارضه تحدثت بان
بانها فاعله على الارض لديها مستودعات
مليئه بالاغذيه والبطانيات والقيام لكن
تقوم بتوزيع عن طريق شركاء محليين عن طريق
المنظمات المحليه الصغيره داخل مناطق
المعارضه لكن في العموم هم يعترفون بان
هناك صعوبات لوجستيه وصعوبه ونتيجه
الخلافات يعني بين الفرقاء على الارض لا
يستطيعون ادخال المساعدات التي تفي
باحتياجات كبرى
للمتضررين يعني مساعدات الامميه والدوليه
لا ترتقي الى مستوى هذه الكارثه حتى هذه
اللحظه عادل يعني المساله تحتاج الى نوع
من الاعراف كيف جميع نوع من التفاهم
الدولي مع النظام لانه العديد من الدول
ايضا يعني لا تطبع مع نظام ولا تقيم اي
علاقات مع النظام لذلك تتفادى التواصل مع
النظام يعني من اصل 22 دوله عربيه فقط
اربع دول عربيه تواصلت وارسلت
مساعدات ضمرها الامارات الجزائر وليبيا
اما باقي الدول العربيه
فتعتقد بان يعني تتفق بها المهارات
التركيه طيب نعم من المطارات التركيه
لايصال المساعدات الى الاجزاء المتضرره في
الشمال شكرا لجمعه عكاش مراسل العربيه من
القامشلي سنكون معك باي تطور جديد جمعه
شكرا جزيلا لك
نعود الى اضنه وتحديدا الى مراسل العربيه
زيدان زنكلو زيدان هل من امل ما زال يحدث
فرق الانقاذ هل من ربما بشائر او مؤشرات
على ايجاد ثغرات في تلك المباني
الكونكريتيه الكونكريتيه التي ربما هي
تحبس صرخات الاستغاثه
زيدان
طيب سنعود الاتصال ابي زيدان زنكلو مراسل
العربيه بعد ان فقدنا الاتصال به الى الان
طيب تبكنت فرق الانقاذ والبحث عن جينا من
انتشار طفل يبلغ من العمره ثلاث سنوات من
تحت انقاذ مبنى سكني بمدينه كهرمان
التركيه بعد 43 ساعه من وقع الزلزال
[موسيقى]
اريد
حطونا ثانيه ليس اكثر وقعها مدمر
وارتداداتها اكثر تدميرا ولا تزال متواصله
تلك هي مده زلزال الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا
وغير حياه اكثر من ثلاثه وعشرين مليون شخص
زلزال بقوه السبعه فاصل تسعه درجه ضرب في
السادس من فبراير على عمق نحو 17 كيلومترا
قرب مدينه غازي عنتاب جنوبي تركيا اي على
عمق عشره كيلو مترات فقط قرب مدينه كهرمان
مرعش وكانت الساعه حينها الواحده وسبعه
عشره دقيقه بتوقيت جرينتش ووفق شهود
الزلزال استمر دقيقه واحده وصفت بدقيقه
الموت مدمرا المباني في المناطق المذكوره
ونوافذ منازل في مدن تبعد نحو 300
كيلومترا شرقا مثل ديار بكر
الزلزال في سوريا لم يكن اخف بل اركع
مباني متهالكه تحاول جاهده التماسك بعد
حرب استمرت 12 عاما لتتجدد صور الحطام
وانتشال الجثث والمصابين والذين قدروا
بالالاف
بعد 11 دقيقه من الزلزال الاول تعرضت
المنطقه لهزه ارتداديه بلغت قوتها 6.7
درجه لتبدا الكارثه حيث لم تنتهي سابقتها
زلزال اخر اعقبها بقوه 7.5 درجه تالته هزه
اخرى بقوه 6 درجات في فتره ما بعد الظهر
مع توقعات بامتداد النشاط الزلزلي الى
فجوه مجاوره
وفيما يحاول سكان عده مناطق في الدولتين
لملمه ما تيسر والانساط لهمهمه عالقين تحت
الانقاض تغص المشافي بالمصابين الذين
ملئوا الممرات دون قدره على علاجهم فيما
اخرون نفذوا من براثن الزلزال لتتكسر على
اجسادهم عاصفه ليست اقل رحمه
الشماليه رمضان سليمان الصحفي سيد رمضان
اهلا بك ما هي الاوضاع لديك
تحياتي لك والاستاده المشاهدين
بالنسبه
للاوضاع بشكل عام في شمال السوري
تحتاج الى تدخل دولي على الفور نحن نعاني
من مشاكل كبيره في اخراج الجثث نعاني
كثيرا في اخراج بعض
العالقين تحت الانقاض نحن الان في سوريا
نحتاج يعني يعني بما تعنيه الكلمه استاذ
كيف بدي اعبر عن هذا الشعور عائلات
باكملها تحت هذه الامراض يوجد كثير من
الاطفال يعني لحد هذه اللحظه عائشون
فرق الانقاذ ليست باستطاعتها الاخراج
الناس يعني هناك نقص في المعدات معدات
الانقاذ معدات الثقيله لازاله الركام
استاذي نحن في سوريا لا يوجد لدينا معدات
ثقيله نحن لا يوجد لدينا اي شيء تخيل انه
الناس نحن بالايادي
الناس في كل شيء يعني حتى في الاظافر عم
تبحث عن عائلات نحن الان مرت علينا 50
ساعه
يعني الاهالي فوق فوق الابنيه تنتظر
اولادها انا رايت بامي اب ينتظر عائلته
بالاكمل تحت هذه البنايه في يده وفي
القزمه وفي يعني منظر هائل لا يوجد لدينا
اي مقومات تساعدنا حتى المعابر التي بيننا
وبين الدوله التركيه مغلقه لا يوجد دخول
معدات ثقيله نحن بحاجه لتدخل دولي شامل
يدخل الى سوريا ويساعد الالاف الالاف من
المدنيين عالان تحت الانقاض خصوصا في عنا
مدينه جنديرس اكثر من 3000 280 بناء نزلوا
على الارض
عائلات عالقين امبارح بعد مرور 48 ساعه
خرجنا اطفال وانتم رايتم الفيديوهات اطفال
انا رايت احد الاطفال يقول لي يقول
للمنقذ يقول لو عمو لو انتو جايين قبل قبل
خمس ساعات كانت ماما عايشه ماما ماتت يعني
نحن عاجزون
نحن عاجزون عن تعبير ما هو حدث ما هو يحدث
في في جنديرس ما هو يحدث في سوريا نحن
نطالب الدول يعني
افهم الصوره اكثر وربما تشرح لي اكثر حتى
تكون ربما انت العين التي ننظر من خلالها
الى جنديرس كيف هو الوضع هناك وضع المباني
وضع الاهالي هل ما زال هناك حتى الساعه
محاولات لانقاذهم الطقس
المعوقات التي تقرا حائلا دون ازاحه
المباني او الركام ركام المباني من فوق
الجثث في جنديرس استاذ اكثر من 220 بناء
ذكرت لك كلها على الارض الشقق السكنيه تعد
في السكان يعني انا بعرف اشق بناء جنب بعض
اكثر من 150 شخص داخل هذه البناء لم يخرج
منهم احد عائشه
فرق الانقاذ لم تستطع الوصول الى هذه
البنايات لبعد مرور 48 ساعه من شده
الصعوبه للوصول الى هذه الابنيه حارات
بالاكمل حارات يعني
المباني بالقرب من بعضها البعض هو ايضا ما
صعب عمليه الوصول اليها اما ان الطرقات
متشققه
لا يوجد طرقات متشققه ولكن الصعوبه في
الابنيه
الملاصقه لبعضها وهي حارات بالاكمل نزلت
على الارض وصعوبه الامطار
والاجواء الطينيه في المدينه جنديرس كمان
لم تساعد الاهالي ولم تساعد فرقه الانقاذ
اصلا لا في سوريا لا يوجد فرق انقاذ اللي
موجودين هم الدفاع المدني الدفاع المدني
غير قادر انه يكون هو المنقذ لانه المعدات
اللي موجوده معي معدات انه تخرج اطفال
عالقين رمضان بس
يعني اذكر هذا الخبر العاجل اعلام النظام
السوري يقول بيهز ارضيه خفيفه شعره بها
سكان اللاذقيه طرطوس حلب وكذلك حمص هل في
ريف حلب شعر قم بذلك هل هناك هزة ارضيه
اليوم
من تقريبا شي
نصف ساعه او اكثر
حدثت عنده في جنديرس هزه وكانت وشعرنا بها
هزات الارتداديه في جنديرس وريف حلب
الشمالي لم تتوقف لم تتوقف اكثر من 30
ارتداديه منذ حدوث الزلزال
طيب رمضان ارجو ان تبقى معي رمضان سليمان
الصحفي من ريف حلب الشمالي ارجو ان تبقى
معي ساعود اليك ساذهب الى اضنه الان ومعي
من هناك مراسل العربيه زيدان زنكلو زيدان
ربما الصوره لهذه الكاميرا والمصور زميلنا
المصور يعطينا تفاصيل ما يحدث الان في
الموقع لديك ولكن هل من تطورات هل من
ناجين ام ما زالت فرق الانقاذ يخرجون فقط
الجثه من الثغره التي فتحوها
نعم عادل كما تحدثنا قبل قليل ماذا ما زال
جهود الانقاذ مستمره في هذا الموقع الذي
نتواجد فيه حتى الان يعني هناك حديث عن
اجين الامل لا يزال موجود هناك خبراء في
بعض في القسم الاخر من هذا الموقع سنحاول
ان ننتقل بكم ومع زميلنا المصور في هذا
ونقترب اكثر هناك في الطرف الاخر هناك
خبراء ما زالوا يحاولون الوصول او البحث
عن ناجين مع لديهم اجهزه متطوره فريق محلي
تركي هناك وايضا مع فريق اجنبي لكن يعني
الظروف صعبه هنا كما نشاهد عدا عن ان هذه
الجهود مستمره وعدا الجهود الكبيره يعني
ساحاول رصد المباني المجاوره المتصدعه
والمهدده بالانهيار في اي لحظه كما في هذا
البناء الذي فيه دعاء حتى الطابق الثالث
حسب ما اشاهد وهو بناء ضخم هذا هذا ايضا
وجود هذا البناء يعني اي هزات لا قدر الله
ربما
تقول بارتفاع عدد ضحايا الزلزال الى سته
الاف ومئتين واربعه
قتيلا حتى الان
62434 قتيلا حتى الان وذلك وفق اداره
الكوارث التركيه معك زيدان تفضل اكمل
نعم كما ذكرت يعني اليوم هذه المباني
المجاوره للموقع هي مهدده بالانهيار في اي
لحظه وكما يعني شاهدتم قبل لحظات التشققات
والتصدعات بهذا المبنى المؤلف تقريبا من
12 طابقا او 14 طابقا لذلك الموضوع جهود
الانقاذ تستمر بحذر شديد يعني حتى الاليات
الضخمه عندما تعمل هناك عمل بدقه شديده
لعدم يعني اي اخطاء لا قدر الله يمكن ان
تؤدي الى كوارث اخرى غير الكارثه التي
نشهدها الان اي هزه ارتداديه قويه لا قدر
الله يمكن ان تؤدي الى انهيار مباني
اضافيه لذلك العمل يتم بشكل دقيق وهي وهو
عمليه صعبه صحيحه
صدقا عادل ونحن منذ يوم امس وحتى هذا
اليوم نشاهد هذه العمليه جهود كبيره من
فرق الانقاذ لكن الظروف يعني او طبيعه
العمل صعبه جدا ايضا الحاله الجويه سيئه
يعني لا تساعد كثيرا فرق الانقاذ بالعموم
يعني الوضع هنا في اضنه رغم كل هذه الظروف
التي الصعبه التي نتحدث عنها افضل بكثير
من باقي الولايات الاخرى
هذه الامدادات والمعونات وبالتالي فرق
الانقاذ يعني كان هناك صعوبه من ايصال هذه
المساعدات لتلك الولايات البعيده نوعا ما
بسبب الطرق وغيرها نعم بالضبط
نعم تلك الولايات عانت في اليوم الاول
تحديدا من الزلزال من عدم او تاثر وصول
المساعدات
وبالتالي تم الاعتماد على الكوادر المحليه
الموجوده في الولايات لكن حجم الدمار
الكبير يعني الفرق المحليه الموجوده في كل
ولايه لا يمكن ان تلبي
كل الاحتياجات في كل المواقع في لاسيما ان
الدمار كان شاملا لمواقع كثيره خصوصا في
هاتاي في مدينه انطاكيا بهاتاي وايضا في
ميناء اسكندرون ومدينه اسكندرون وفي مدينه
كهرمان مرعش لذلك الوضع كان سيئا
والامدادات تاخرت نوعا ما حتى وصلت خصوصا
الاليات الثقيله اليات الحفر الثقيله
والاليات الضخمه التي يتم من خلال تدمير
الكتل الخرسانيه وازاله الكتل الخرسانيه
من مواقع الدمار هذه الاليات لا يمكن
نقلها بشكل عن طريق المروحيات او جوا
الانقاذ ولا حتى الاحياء
تحت الركام لذلك الجهود تقريبا الحديث عن
تضاعف الاعداد سواء طواقم الانقاذ او حتى
الاليات التي تشارك في عمليات الانتاج
شكرا زيدان مراسله العربيه من اضنه ومن
هذا الموقع الذي وفق زيدان يقول بانه وصله
ايضا بالاضافه الى الطواقم التركيه طاقم
اجنبيه وصل الى هذا المكان في محاوله
الانقاذ
الضحايا تحت الركام وايجاد اي من الناجين
هنا عود الى ريف حلب الشمالي ومعنى من
هناك رمضان سليمان الصحفي رمضان اعود اليك
من جديد لسؤالك عن هذه
المره الهزه الارضيه هناك مباني نتحدث عن
مباني كثيره ربما هي سقطت
اصحابه على رؤوس اصحابها ولكن ايضا هناك
مباني
تاثرت وهل غادرها السكان نحو مناطق امنه
او على الاقل ملاجئ امنه سواء مقر لاذو
بها
اذكر لك الحادثه باول لحظات الزلزال سيدي
في جليس خرج الاهالي يعني هروب من الابنيه
التي لم
تسقط عليهم هرب الاهالي باتجاه المخيمات
تخيل انه المخيمات التي تحت تحت الامطار
تحت
الطين والبرد هي التي اوت اهلنا من مدينه
جنديرس لا يوجد حاليا اي
عائله تسكن في مدينه جنديرس سوى القليل
خرج الاهالي الى المخيمات لا يوجد عندنا
ماوى نحن يعني
عالقون بمازق كبير انساني لا يوجد لا يوجد
شيء يعني ينتقل اليه الى الاهالي يعني
يوجدوا اماكن يناموا فيها اول يوم في
الزنزال انا رايت بعيني الناس نامت والله
الناس نامت بالشوارع الناس نامت تحت المطر
الناس نامت
يعني في العراق برد ومطر
صار 48 ساعه امبارح في عالم لحد الان ما
وصلها اكل ما وصلها حتى خبز الناس اللي
موجوده على الابنيه عم تبحث اكثر من 48
ساعه في معدات
قليله يعني حتى الاكل ما وصلهم
الماء مقطوع الكهرباء في جن انا هلا عم
احاكيك استاذ مداخل معك من براد جنديرس
لانه لا يوجد عندنا كهرباء ولا يوجد
انترنت ولا يوجد اي مقومات الحياه في
تعتبر شبه خاليه مدينه منكوبه نعود الى
جنديرس نبحث مع فرق الانقاذ نرى
الاطفال نرى يعني احد الاطفال قلت لك يقول
عموله وراجعين قبل خمس ساعات لقيته انا
امي كانت عايشه جنبي طيب يا استاذ نحن نحن
بحاجه للتدخل دولي نحن بسوريا
يعني حالنا كارثه نحن بحاجه يعني الله
المستعان الله المستعان طيب يعني هل هناك
ايضا القدره على انشاء
مستشفيات ميدانيه هل هذا
موجود خاصه انه الحديث يتم عن انه
المستشفيات مكتظه بالجرحى وقد لا تستوعب
يعني هؤلاء او هذه الاعداد
استاذ بالنسبه للموضوع المستشفيات
المستشفيات مليئه جدا
الجثث الجثث امام المستشفيات من يريد
التعرف على جثه يعرفها يراها امام امام
بالشارع لا يستطيع الدخول الى المشفى لانه
المشفى مليئه بالجرحى مليئه بالمصابين
المشافي في شمال السوري تعبد امتلات يعني
المشافي بحاجه
اخي سوريا سوريا يعني الشمال السوري
بالتحديد بحاجه لكل شيء بحاجه لتدخل نحن
نريد الان اخراج الارواح التي ما زالت
نسمع اصوات ما زال نسمع اصوات تحت هذه
الانقاض ونحن لا نستطيع اخراج احد من طلب
شمالي الصحفي رمضان سليمان شكرا جزيلا لك
وعنكم الله
الله يصبرني فيكم دخيلك
قل لا اله الا الله
بدي اروح معهم
ما شاء الله ما شاء الله
الحمد لله على السلامه يا عمو
[موسيقى]
شوي شوي على الحديد
يا رب بسم الله
الله اكبر ما شاء الله
[موسيقى]
احسنتي
يلا يلا
شوي بس
الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز وولي العهد
الامير محمد بن سلمان وجه مركز الملك
سلمان لليغاثه والاعمال الانسانيه بتسيير
جسر جوي الى تركيا وسوريا وتقديمي مساعدات
صحيه وايوائيه وغذائيه لتخفيف اثار
الزلزال كما وجه الملك سلمان والامير محمد
بن سلمان بتنظيم حمله شعبيه عبر منصه ساهم
لمساعدات ضحايا الزلزال
مركز الملك سلمان وضع الخطه
لتدخل الانساني عاجل يركز على الاحتياجات
الاساسيه خلال المرحله الاوليه مرحله
التدخل الاولي او ما يسمى بالتدخل
الانساني العاجل
هذه المرحله سوف تشمل الحقيقه تقديم
سلال غذائيه او الحقيقه الحرص كل الحرص
على تامين الاحتياجات في مجال القطاع
الغذائي كذلك القطاع الاخر هو اولويه
هو قطاع الايواء تامين الخيام وكذلك كل ما
يتعلق بالحقيبه الايوائيه المعياريه التي
يقدمها عاده مركز الملك سلمان خلال هذه
الازمات هناك كذلك اهتمام كبير جدا
بالاحتياجات في المجال الطبي تامين
الاحتياجات سواء كانت من ادويه او سواء
الوريديه او غيرها بحيث تسد الاحتياج
تساعد الحقيقه في نوعا ما تامين الاستقرار
للحاله الصحيه الى المتضررين في هذه
الفتره
اعلنها حلف شمال الاطلسيه النيتو رساله
طواقمه ومعدات انقاذ الى تركيا بعد تعرض
مناطقها الجنوبيه لزلزاله مدمر ووفق بيان
الناتو تم نشر اكثر من 1400 عنصر من طواقم
الانقاذ قدمت قدمت من 30 دوله عضو وحليف
للنيتو من بينها السويد وفنلندا واوضح
البيان ان طواقم الانقاذ شملت طواقم بحث
وانقاذ واطفاء اضافه الى فرق هندسيه
وطواقمه طبيه
اعلنت الولايات المتحده انها تعمل مع
شركاء لها في سوريا لتقديم المساعدات
للمنكوبيين جراء الزلزال على الرغم من عدم
اعترافها بالحكومه السوريه
وقالن الذي يقود الاستجابه الميدانيه في
الوكاله الامريكيه الدوليه للتنميه
الدوليه ان ان الوكاله تعيد توجيه
المساعده التي كانت تقدم اصلا لمساعده
السوريين المتضررين من الحرب واوضح الين
ان المساعده الامريكيه في سوريا تساهم في
جهود الانقاذ وتقدم احتياجات عاجله اخرى
بما في ذلك توفير الماوى والطعام
معنا من واشنطن الصحفيه المتخصصه في
العلاقات الدوليه ايهاب عباس سيدي ايهاب
يعني اليوم الموقف ربما السياسه تطغى حتى
على الوضع الانساني بينما نرى
الحديث الان كل الجهود منصبه على تركيا
ولا احد لسوريا حتى ما الخبر الذي قراناه
هو تحويل المساعدات من المتضررين جراء
الحرب الى المتضررين جراء الزلزال بالنسبه
للولايات المتحده
نعم صباح الخير استاذ عادل واهلا
المشاهدين بالفعل يعني اتفق مع حضرتك ان
الجهود الغربيه فيما يبدو معظمها متوجه
لتركيا ولا يوجد الا الفتات متوجه لسوريا
اعتقد سوريا اليوم في حاجه كبيره لفرق
انقاذ هذا هو الامر الاهم فرق انقاذ
لمحاوله انقاذ هؤلاء العلاقين تحت الرماد
والركاب والانقاد
منذ اكثر ربما من يومين لان هذه هي الفرصه
الوحيده يعني تبقى ربما كما يقول الخبراء
اربعه ايام حتى يكون هناك فرصه للحصول على
احياء اخراجهم من طبعا تحت الانقاد بشكل
كبير الولايات المتحده الامريكيه اداره
للاسف الشديد كانت هناك مطالبات دوليه من
من كل الجهات الدوليه برفع العقوبات على
سوريا في هذه المرحله الا انها قالت انها
يعني لن تقوم بهذا الامر ولكن اعلنت انها
ستغض الطرف عن تقديم المساعدات
ويعني لن تقوم بمحاسبه من يقوم بتقديم
المساعدات في هذا التوقيت للمتضررين في
سوريا هذا الموقف من الاداره الامريكيه
بالمناسبه لا يعجب المواطنين الامريكيين
وهم كثر يعني وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي هنا
في الولايات المتحده الذين يتابعون
الاحداث لحظه بلحظه ولقطه بلقطه عبر وسائل
الاعلام المختلفه يتعاطفون مع الانسان
الذي هو موجود تحت الانقاض بغض النظر اذا
كان هذا الانسان سوريا او تركيا الجميع
تنفطر قلوبهم للمشاهد التي يشاهدونها وبدا
المجتمع الامريكي يتفاعل مع ما يشاهده من
احداث ويطالب بتقديم المساعدات والعون بل
منهم من فتح حسابات
للتبرعات لتركيا و لسوريا ولو حتى بشكل
بسيط بقدر المستطاع يحاول حتى المواطنون
التغلب على
هل هذا سيعرضهم للمسائله طالما ان هناك
ايضا قوانين تمنع ربما تقديم اي نوع من
المساعدات الى الى سوريا اتحدث هنا تحديدا
عن سوريا اليوم اذا كانت الولايات المتحده
تفرض حذرا على النظام ماذا عن المناطق
الاخرى التي تقع تحت سيطره المعارضه مثلا
هذا هو السؤال الكبير يعني لماذا لا توجه
الولايات المتحده المساعداتها مباشره
للمعارضه التي تدعمها يعني نعلم ان واشنطن
تدعم المعرض الموجوده في شمال الغربي
سوريا قوات قصد وقوه حمايه الشعب الكرديه
كل هذه الاماكن من الممكن ان تتعرض
لمساعده مباشره من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه كما قلت لحضرتك يبدو ان واشنطن
لا تابح في هذا التوقيت بتقديم المساعدات
بشكل فعال وفوري للسوريين سواء معارضه او
نظامهم فقط المساعدات تقدم للجانب التركي
بشكل اكبر
ويتركون محاولات تقديم المساعدات للجانب
السوري طبعا لربما بقيه الدول وايضا
البعثات العامله هناك الامريكيه شكرا ليها
صحفيه المتخصص في العلاقات الدوليه ايهاب
عباس من واشنطن شكرا جزيلا لك الان نذهب
الى مدير المرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان
رامي عبد الرحمن من القاهره ساد رامي يعني
لابد ان اسالك عن الحصيله حتى وان لم يكن
هناك اي ارقام ربما
موثوقه ولكن الوضع الانساني يفرض
نسال هل من ناجين
هل بالناجين صباح الخير
قد يكون هناك ناجي او ناجيين او عشره ولكن
هل من الذين ليس لاجئين هل هناك المزيد من
الجساس تخرج هل هناك مزيد من السوريين
ينتظرون ان كانوا على قيد الحياه تحت
الانقاذ من يخرجهم من تحت هذه الارقام
لذلك اقول ان يعني الوضع ماساوي تحدث
الضيف في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه عن
امريكا تسبح وامريكا لا تسبح المساعدات
الامريكيه ان كانت الامريكه تريد ان تساعد
بخارج مناطق النظام فلتاتي المساعدات الى
مناطق سيطره قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه وتدخل
عبر معبر عون الدادات لمناطق السيطره
التركيه التي دخلت منه يوم امس جسر
السوريين كانوا قد قتلوا في الزلزال داخل
الاراضي التركيه لذلك اقول لك بان
الانسانيه يجب ان تبتعد عن كل عقوبات يبدا
تتعد عن حتى نكون حتى نكون دقيقين ضيفنا
ايهاب عباس قال حتى في الداخل الامريكيون
ليسوا راضيين عن موقف الا
عن الاداره الامريكيه بل ان بعضهم قدم ولو
بشكل رمزي بعض المساعدات في تركيا
هذا هو السؤال الكبير
استاذ رامي نستطيع ان تنتقل
الاراضية لذلك اقول لك بان اليوم الموضوع
انساني يعني المعابر مع تركيا هي مغلقه
المعابر مع تركيا هي مفتوحه فقط بالدخول
الجثث من داخل الاراضي التركيه لا لماذا
لا تدخل المساعدات الى تلك المناطق وايضا
الطائرات التي حطت في مطار حلب والتي هبطت
في مطار دمشق تحمل المساعدات لابناء الشعب
السوري نحن نتحدث عن الاسنان وسبعون منطقه
وايجابيه نكتشف بانه هناك مناطق جديده
يعني يوجد فيها دمار يوجد فيها خسائر
بشريه يعني عندما نقول جبله تستخرج منها
امس جثث يعني من تحت الانقاذ مباني امس
يعني امس بعد ايام الجبله لم يجتاح زلزال
مثلما اجتاح مناطق في ادلب مناطق في احياء
في مدينه حلب لذلك اقول يعني ماذا عن
الذين الان هم تحت الركام سواء
الاعداد
للاسف الاعداد ما هي الحصيله حتى الان
الحصيله بشكل قطعي بشكل قطعي وليست نتحدث
عن ارقام تقديريه تتحدث
عن الارض موثوقه الى الان نحو 2700 بشكل
قطعي يعني نتحدث عن مئات فجاه المتحدث عن
مئات يعني
حقيقه امر يعني يعني عندما يحدثنا من
جنديرس على سبيل المثال يقول بان هناك
مئتين ليس 84 الدفاع المدني هناك 259 مبنى
تهدم بشكل كامل او شكل جزئي هناك لا يسال
في تلك البقعه الجغرافيه الصغيره في عفرين
ناس تحت الارصاد هذه المنطقه لوحدها قد
يصل عدد الذين قتلوا فيها الى 900 بلده
صغيره قف على باقي المناطق اي ان العدد قد
يفوق الثلاثه الاف بكثير امس قلنا قد يفوق
قد يصل العدد الى 3000 قد يصل عدد الى
3000 اليوم لذلك يعني الامر حقيقه الامر
محير ومسهل شكرا جزيلا لمدير المرصد
السوري لحقوق الانسان رامي عبد الرحمن رغم
هذه الاعداد التي تتزايد ورغم المئات التي
تدخل كل يوم الى ارقام مع الضحايا والقتل
تحديدا الا ان ثمه امل بان القادم ربما
يحمل من تحت الركام صرخه حياه ومولود جديد
الى العالم مره اخرى الان ننتقل الى
الزميل احمد وايضا الاستكمال هذه التغطيه
المتواصله من العربيه
لاحداث الزلزال في سوريا
وتركيا على راس الساعه دمتم في امان الله